I was undocumented youth maybe we do not
have the boat the power to vote but we
have the power to influence or trunk
from Arizona to come in protest against
bro me I want him to give us a stance on
immigration like I want his answer he's
been pushing away everything to do with
immigration very much he advocates for
self deportation he is against very
logical legislation like the dream act
like deferred action have you supported
barack obama's policies on immigration i
have and like we want more i am actually
in support of Obama Obama's deported a
record number of immigrants are you
disappointed with how policies have
turned out so far yes to say yes because
the fraction is just one step President
Obama has record deportations on his
administration he has he pass deferred
action which you know we're thankful for
that but we know that is not the end
battle do you think it's curious that he
really just started getting this into
full force in prime election season yeah
I think maybe it was a political
movement that is something that really
we have to think about it could be but
it's an opportunity that we're getting
and we're taking advantage of it before
the dreamers act were you were you ever
afraid for the current policies that
Obama was enforcing oh yeah we're such
as it was like come from Arizona the
like one of the most anti-immigration
states it was even hard to like leave
the house why why do you still support
him after that um because right now it's
Obama and Romney Obama against Romney
Obama wins who are people supposed to
vote for I mean Obama's record on
immigration has been terrible Romney's
isn't looking too promising so what are
you supposed to do so I think though
with us in mind and I honestly can't see
that leading you to voting for Romney so
I'm asking my friends and allies to vote
with me in mind with dreamers in mind so
do you mean voting for Obama
I'm saying vote for me right now we're
taking the pros and cons out of
everybody is there an answer should
people protest and not even vote no we
need you to vote and I think that's why
dreamers are making that part of our
campaign we're doing Civic electoral
work very intentionally this year what
about a third party candidate like say
Gary Johnson I do think it might be a
little late in the game but you know
next election we can work on putting a
better candidate out there